we've got our pr child prodigy here you
know we've got an over
overachiever here her name is jules kuhn
and she um
she really she got into the university
of davis uc davis
give her a round of applause and she um
you know because i watched the uh the
varsity blues uh scandal documentary
last night
oh right with um lori laughlin and all
those
uh rick singer the college admissions
scandal have you heard of that jules
yeah
did you watch the documentary no but you
told me about that but i watch the
documentary it'll really
really maybe piss you off but i also
told you how proud of i was i was of you
today did i not yeah what did i say
child prodigy i called you a child
apology because
here's this um provincial here's this
provincial farm girl
yeah from somewhat she grew up in the
city guys from some remote islands with
malls
bridges right just let's let's create a
narrative here that's going to be
interesting a cosmopolitan right
so he's a he's a farm girl who she grew
up with
just rice she you know a patty of rice
and she she was out there farming and
she had a vision
and she had um she she
was inspired to do more so here's
she didn't speak english or the
philippine language she spoke english
learned both in a year and she crawled
out over that
rice paddy and she took she she found a
plane
to get out here and now she's going to
uc davis it's a beautiful thing
do you remember when she first came here
yeah i go
can she function as a human you're 16
only jules
yeah oh wow so long ago yeah she was so
meek she had she was like overall
but that's permanent now you did that to
yourself i keep telling her you know
your parents always like sit up straight
sit up straight
and you don't really you don't realize
the value of sitting up straight until
you're a permanent hunchback like me
yeah
and she could um one of her ears are
abnormally large
so if she was like dumbo she would fly
in a circle
you know what what do you call um is
there a word in english for people whose
ears stick out
what is there a word in english for for
people who there is a word but i no
longer
i could no longer say it because i don't
think it canceled what is it
it starts with an r cauliflower here
[Music]
yeah and so like people like tape the
their babies
no you know what that is [ __ ] person
no i'm proud of you i told your child
prodigy and i think that
uh i honestly honestly as a father
as a father as a stepfather i'm so proud
of you and um
i just uh there's a high there's some
high expectations
you got to cure something well let's
tell the audience how we found out about
it
where were we we were in the parking lot
of
lucky boy burritos in pasadena we were
here i don't know if you guys know this
but um
i'm a little connoisseur when it comes
to breakfast burritos
i've had all of them and i've had cold
facts a bunch of times
i've had um every waffle house you can
imagine in l.a and i have to say and i
said this the other day
lucky boy has if you're ever in pasadena
they have the best breakfast burrito i
would believe on planet earth
what makes it so perfect um
what makes it perfect is um i like